gionis explose à bercy depuis quatre
jours il présente son show très rock
avec des chansons récentes et anciennes
et avec en final un orchestre
symphonique michel vial
m
un jour je gagne ma vie cette firme snc
de faire cette percée messieurs faut pas
brûler plus ma vie sous les projecteurs
que quelqu'un qui va s'emmerder la vie
dans un avion passer toute une journée
je crois que mon étiez peut-être plus
amusant quand même lorsque vous dites ce
que je fais n'a pas d'importance ça veut
dire que vous avez le sens du dérisoire
oui bien sûr ce que je fais c'est vrai
que c'est pas important je vois que les
la chose importante c'est suspect lors d
un peu d'espoir si son départ comme moi
j'étais de tête ramé à mes débuts
ces deux villes ne pouvoir rêver à un
jour pourquoi pas moi
je suis né dans la rue par une nuit
d'orage
je suis dans la rue
le ca
est-ce qu'on se remet facilement d'une
jeunesse aussi extraordinaire que la
vôtre il ya danger c'est que sur l'apa
sur les pas assez solide
quelques par soi même on peut vite avoir
la tête qui vont comme lui je n'étais
pas revenue de tout pour autant blancs
au verre que je crois qu'on peut
j'ai fait ce métier parce que j'étais
valable et si vous le dirai pas te dire
apple aura peut-être poussé johnny en
quoi penser vu coller à votre époque où
êtes vous désormais hors du temps en on
les a mais heureusement dieu merci parce
que c'est quand même extraordinaire qui
est trois générations de fans qui sort
qui se réunissent à vos concerts
là